all right we have Steven Jackson we
don't waste any more time just go all
right so here we go you got two teams
you played two out of the four teams you
Rams the Patriots will get to the
Patriots in a second but first of all do
you root for the Rams like are you a
Rams fan because of your time there
that's a no that was a body language it
is bad I know you're one of the all-time
greats and Rams history it's you
Dickerson and girly and Faulk what's the
weight like that's where I want to go
right because he's gonna ask my question
now to is do you alright so first of all
do you root for the man's just fit start
I do but I it's bittersweet right yeah
it's like you give them almost a decade
nine years you give them everything you
have never better than eight and eight
right nine seasons I had six coaches
right County interim coach yeah yeah so
all I know is turnover
yeah and now to see the success of this
one for you is the greatest show on turf
yeah after you is Sean McVeigh this off
explosion right in between yeah I'm just
the meat yeah so I do I mean you're one
of the great running backs of all time
your 18th on the all-time rushing list
wild do you feel like you're almost like
the forgotten man not only as a whole
but for the Rams like I feel like people
just go Marshall Faulk and Todd Gurley
and they forget that you were like a
super stud in the NFL for a long time
what what my favorite questions of fans
that say they're broke fans is who's the
leading rusher for them the LA Rams
right most people say Eric Dickerson is
like well you don't know your history
you didn't watch me
oh yeah alright and I that still the
frustrating part is you know understand
that team leadership and team wins come
together and I just wasn't a part of
that team yeah but when you talk about
individual and what a person put out on
the field well we worked hard to do yeah
yeah I just want some acknowledgement
and right time I feel like I'll get
skipped over and it's not because of my
talent I know that it's just because I
just had a bad break yeah yeah it's
everyone says that wins isn't a
statistic but yet we treat it like it's
the greatest statistic of all you're
right yeah that's kind of how it goes
but what's funny is is then you go to
the Patriots which there's nothing
better than Bill Belichick with a guy
that hasn't been getting respect from
another team having with Corey Dillon it
happened with like every safety wide
receivers
that would Chad Johnson our friend you
go there what was your first meeting
with Bella check like what were your
what was a great Bella check story about
who he really is my story Bella tag is
he calls me in December LeGarrette
Blount goes down gets her that was the
answers out of danger he goes down and
I'm retired at this point in my head and
it's Bella tag you know that voice it's
very distinct and he goes Stephen yeah
yeah exactly
he go Stephen I got it I got a question
for you do you want to play football
again and I'm like in my head like of
course I do
yeah but I'm not very December this is a
New England Patriots and I'm a man of
pride I don't want to look bad like a
laugh
my last carry I felt I still look like
myself I didn't want to get to New
England and look like a shell of myself
yeah and they're people that all he's
you know he's terrible he's trash so I
was more nervous about public opinion
about what I would look like so I said
coach he's given me two weeks to get in
shape
I'll come what was it like going there
seeing their day-to-day preparation and
specifically like the AFC Championship
getting ready for the Broncos that year
what that was like being a part of that
organization during that time so will
you get there you realize that there's
no place like it in the NFL which laughs
my stops yeah there's not a lot of
pictures in the hallways there's not a
lot of mimimi
you know but well I found the most
interesting to your question is getting
ready for the AFC game against the
Denver Broncos if I recall right he
asked me to talk to the team and he
wanted me to talk to them about my NFL
experience I'm like what do I have to
teach these guys you know you guys been
to now eight consecutive AFC Champions
right
Gronkowski laughing he goes I've never
had not a bye yeah oh my god I want to
play all twice first year in the last
year yeah he's the Laughing like you got
a bad break so he asked me to talk about
my plight sometime in the team about my
story and my story goes there's a
there's a part of my career where I won
six games in three years Wow I'm talking
to the team about me winning six games
in three years yeah and you could just
hear a pin drop and they just couldn't
believe the amount of eight consecutive
thousand yards rushing but the lack of
the wins that go with it it's almost
like those guys wanting to win that game
for me
yeah and that was a special moment
because I didn't think my story wasn't
anything I thought I was just a
privilege to be there but that it was
twofold and that they wanted me to kind
of cap off my career or what the win it
meant a lot to me and I know I'll always
forever be great you got a touchdown in
the AFC Championship game in Denver I
think he was trying to like like you
know Belichick like is he trying to show
like hey you guys are spoiled and not
kind of be grateful this sup yeah okay
you can't take it for granted right and
I think if you're grim Kowski for
example yeah he doesn't know anything
else yeah yeah he owning those Brady
Belichick and playoff wins
Cincinnati's like that yeah yeah yeah
now they're in a similar situation they
haven't been in that situation since
your speech in that game of a road AFC
championship game and since 2004 they've
been in the playoffs like 13 times this
is only happened three times and the
Patriots are Owen three went through in
the room I'm curious what is pella check
like the week of an AFC championship
game very relaxed everybody and I would
say the whole team that's the dad with
the other thing that's impressive from
the running back coach to the special
teams coach so even if the team chaplain
nothing it is nothing's different there
it is normal football in January
February is normal to them the regular
City sounds like you were in a bizarro
world when you're like I've never been
here before this is insane everyone's
like it's Tuesday Stephen take a seat
I'm normally looking at my passport I'm
in Costa Rica so where's the vision or a
week my only other thing is if you could
say anything to the basketball Stephen
Jackson yeah what would you say to him
snack 5 with uh-huh
do you guys like talk to the Stephen
Jackson's talk to it you know we haven't
talked in a while we've ran into each
other before coincident enough it was in
a nightclub in San Antonio and I we got
each other's bills that's how did you
you don't want to mess that NBA
it's a space right so there's been some
mix ups that's all I love it we're happy
to have you man thank you Mary yeah
thanks for coming but real seriously